foreign
in Oklahoma City hey Tim what's up man
hello what's up
hi I'm 53 years old I'm going through a
divorce
and I spent the last couple years as a
stay-at-home dad homeschooling my son
and I really I don't I don't have I
don't have anything I don't I mean the
baby steps is
definitely where I'm at I I wish I'd
have known about all of this sooner in
life
but I didn't have parents my mom taught
us to cocaine and lose and my dad taught
us to fight in booze
and now I'm going through a divorce my
wife's trajectory is
going out of the roof
she gets a lot of Facebook attention and
Instagram attention and that is a
contributing factor
but I don't I'm I'm scared I'm 53 years
old and I'm scared yeah because I don't
I don't I have the zero
hmm I'm sorry man
that's not your fault no I know but
you're my brother and I
um you know I mean my parents have some
brain but they don't
they've never been parents you know
that's right they did the best they
could do and it was really terrible you
know my Dad tried to throw me through
play glass windows yeah yeah yeah yeah
and I I know I know
hold on hold on hold on
the moment it hurts
you start deflecting and want to go
backwards you want to go forward you're
going to talk about them you talk about
someone else
yeah I just sit in it for a second okay
it hurts
because out of what out of this hurt
right here we call it grief
out of this comes that scary terrifying
question
what are you gonna do next
exactly okay
and I think with all my heart
um you've got childhood traumas that are
killing you from the inside out I have
no doubt about that yes
um I bet you've got regrets with your
kids you have kids
I do I have a 36 year old daughter a 24
year old daughter and a seven-year-old
son okay
different parents different Brothers
okay
you've had a long road right
yeah I'm tired there you go
tired I can hear it
I can hear it in you
um
I don't know what to do I mean like I
said I'm 53 it's it's literally starting
over I have I'm sure there's another
bank account
I live day to day uh
on
just trying to get by actually you know
yeah and uh I you know
I don't I'm I'm my body's broken I can't
do construction like I did I live
in rural community uh the largest
metropolitans they don't live in
Oklahoma City per se I was outside open
the city it's an hour and a half away
okay
are you ready for everything to be
different
you have been chasing different my whole
life and every time I do a little bit
okay
who's somebody you can call right now
that's a friend
an old friend somebody you trust
I mean I do but I I don't no no no you
do you don't want to
I don't want anyone to know how bad it
is and you know what that is that's
shame my brother and that will kill you
I have a lifetime of it I know Secrets
will kill you
it holds you if you look at Facebook
I could care less about face positive I
could care less about Facebook it's a
fantasy it's not right you could care
less about Facebook Instagram all that
crap could care less you need a real
friend in your life that you can look at
and say I don't know what to do next
and the moment you say that in the
presence of somebody else that you love
and trust you will feel lighter than you
have felt in 30 years
yeah I have I've reached out and I get
the
I mean people love me but they don't
know how to help me okay
it's got to be a both hand
okay you need to sit down with someone
and say I need help making a plan
whether that's a pastor whether that's a
local counselor at a Community
Counseling Center that's not going to
charge you anything whether that's a
friend that you trust that owns a
business that you have a sketchy past
with because you've messed them over a
few times I've not ever done that I know
hey I'm just putting it out there
brother I'm on your team
I'm just saying the time for ego and the
time for Pride it helps people when I
couldn't even help myself that's left
the building
and
you happen to have hit the bottom
in the single greatest job economy in
the history of this country
and now is the time to go to Taco Bell
Now's the Time to go work at Arby's now
is the time to go I agree I agree I'm
just so far away and then like then it's
time then listen joint custody of my son
so I every other day you know I just and
I don't have a support group like she
does she has her parents
Tim
you're gonna have to make some
short-term sacrifices to turn your thing
around
I don't want to abandon my son I know
but in an effort to not quote unquote
abandon him you're going to drown
yourself
in six months of going to get yourself
financially stable getting a place to
live
getting a job or two jobs or three jobs
getting some not respect from your
community but respect from that guy you
see in the mirror because you don't like
that guy
getting some respect back from that guy
is going to come back and you're going
to be six inches taller with that little
boy
mentally I need my son though because I
don't nope nope I don't have anybody
else and I feel I already feel like he
he aligns with his mom and he pulls away
and when the daisy pulls away I almost
can't deal with it
because like I can't go into how bad it
was for me I tried my whole life to get
my love from my mother and she's been
nothing but cruel
I was suicidal at one time and you know
she didn't care
and you know sometimes you just want
that parent to say hey
and I'm never going to get that okay
I don't want to do that to my son
Tim where are you living right now
right now in the marital house until
uh she's at her parents is that a month
from now how far away until you don't
have a place to live anymore
a couple of probably about a week okay
so that is our A1 we've got to have
somewhere to live you're not going to be
homeless you got to take care of your
son we got to put food on the table do
you have any bills that you have to pay
any debt
I'm I let my truck go back I have no
debt I have I have I have no doubt how
much money do you have in the bank
nothing zero dollars zero dollars okay
then we gotta go to work today and we
gotta find a local community a local
church and we've got to let them know
that you are not doing well and that you
need some help right now and see what
they can do for you that might be a roof
over your head that might be some a meal
but you gotta stop living alone
and you can't put this on your son
in a group of 100 people I'm alone Tim
do you abuse your son
no hell no okay listen listen listen do
you abandon your son
I feel like I'm gonna have to in order
to get on my feet there is nothing
similar about you and your mom
there is nothing good things on purpose
don't listen to me listen to me you are
not your mom you are not your dad
your separation from your son for six
months to go somewhere where you can
actually get work
and get yourself straightened out
get yourself some counseling that you
need is not abandonment that's called
love
don't tell me that people get who go on
deployment are abandoning their kids or
people who go to to rehab for 30 days or
60 days or 90 days or six months or
abandoning their kids they're not
because getting yourself Tim in the most
stable healthiest position
emotionally financially all of this that
is the biggest gift you can give to your
son
because when you are you know even the
conversation we're having right now
uh the the kind of the back and forth I
mean I I hear the pain I hear the pain
in your voice and the story that you've
been through I can't even imagine
and the best thing you can do Tim for
your son the biggest gift you can give
him is is a healthy dad a dad that is
supporting himself that may not it may
not be it's not going to be the luxury
life on Facebook like you're comparing
it to none of that like cut all that out
but to have a dad who is stable and can
love him well with a full healthy heart
that is the biggest gift you can give
him Tim so you're not abandoning him
you're doing something you're giving him
a gift by doing this maybe you can do it
all today let some people know I'm not
okay